>>Female presenter: Micah Sifry, author of
the new book "Wikileaks and the Age of Transparency."
Micah Sifry is the co-founder and curator
of The Personal Democracy Forum, editor of
its award-winning techPresident.com blog,
and a senior technology advisor to the Sunlight
Foundation. He has written a number of books
and is a member of the board of the Consumers
Union, also the adjunct professor at the political
science department at the City University
of New York Graduate Center, where he teaches
a course called Writing Politics. Please welcome
Micah Sifry to our stage.
>>Micah Sifry: Hi. [clapping] Alright. Well,
thank you, um, thanks a lot, Kate. It's great
to be here. It's always fun to be at Google.
Um. And I kind of was thinking uh as I as
I headed down here, that, uh, it was particularly
right to be talking about this book at Google,
given Google's own mission, um, to organize
all the world's information and and make it
universally accessible. Um, I think the the
topic of transparency ought to be and probably
is, ah, quite close to the hearts of of lots
of people who who support that mission. Um,
so I'm hoping that, ah, we'll get a chance
to to um sort of engage in a little bit of
a dialog about how you think about WikiLeaks
and how you think about the larger transparency
movement as it relates also to what Google
does. Um, 'cause I think, uh, um, you know,
we live in in a rapidly changing world and
a big piece of that change is is ah ah being
fostered at places like this.
Um, I'm gonna start by actually talking about
just two quick episodes that have nothing
to do with WikiLeaks. Um, and just to say
I wrote this book, ah, very quickly, it's
not a big book. It's a little book. It's meant
to be, uh, in some ways, a connect, a connect-the-dots
kind of book. Because when WikiLeaks happened,
I thought while all this attention is going
to Julian Assange and Bradley Manning and
there are all kinds of important questions
raised by ah what they've done, but um there's
a danger that, you know, our media will just
obsess on, you know, the celebrity aspect
of this and miss the larger picture. And the
larger picture is that what WikiLeaks represents
is a symptom of a of a larger trend. Um, and
if Julian Assange and WikiLeaks didn't exist,
um, sooner or later somebody would have done
this. The technology to do this, build the
state list platform or multi-state platform
that's relatively free from state intervention
to enable whistle blowers to post internal
documents, that this has been coming. Um,
and I suspect a year from now we may not be
talking about Julian Assange anymore, but
we will certainly be talking about this larger
phenomenon of user-generated transparency.
Um, so I wanted to just start by by with two
quick episodes.
The first one is, ah, is there anybody here
from Croatia? OK, so you've probably not heard
of this story, um, so ah, one of the people
I profile in the book in the section about
the international transparency movement is
a guy named Marko Rakar, who several years
ago he had a printing business, um, and ah,
a tax auditor came to him and basically demanded
a bribe, ah, in order to get a clean tax bill.
And Marko refused to pay the bribe and as
a result this guy basically hounded his hounded
him out of business, drove his printing business
into bankruptcy. And this was early in the
days of blogging and he decided to start a
blog called Pollitika, which is sort of like
the Daily Kos. Uh, is it's one of these sites
where you have uh anybody can create an account
and um participate, not just the blogger who
started it, and it's evolved into the leading
political blog in Croatia, a country of about
ah eight, seven, eight million people. Um,
it's probably got ah you know five or six
thousand core contributors, um, and, you know
it's one of the top-read sites in the country.
Um, and Marko is, is, uh, part of a generation
of people in Croatia who are trying to move
that country from being very much an authoritarian
system to something that's more open and democratic.
Um, two years ago somebody leaked him a database
of the entire, uh, voter file for Croatia.
Um, Croatia has this weird circumstance which
is that it has more registered voters than
it has citizens. Um, and that's partly a relic
of being part of Yugoslavia and that you know
people you know the boundaries of Croatia
include people who, like, probably lived across
the road from where the boundary was put,
OK, but ah the fact is is that they don't
police registration very well and there's
a ton of corruption around voter registration
because if you're, ah, well first of all you
get some benefits, ah, but more importantly
local officials use it to cement their power.
So he got this database and he um had the
uh wisdom to put it online in a searchable
way so that you could look up any village
and any address and see how many people were
registered to vote at that address and people
started swarming into this, on his site, and
discovered towns where like there'd be an
address like ah you know the town of Dusina,
there'd be an address the equivalent of 0
Broadway, OK, and it has 400 people registered
at it, OK? And what was quickly exposed is
the fact that local mayors or local police
were letting people register at fake addresses,
using their votes to stay in office in local
elections, right? So this is about keeping
local power structures intact. Um, by posting
this database Marko set off a firestorm in
the country. It was top headlines, in every
paper, on the evening news and it set off
ah a debate which is now culminating in a
constitutional change that will prevent it
anyone from being registered to vote in more
than one country. [laughter] Right, you're
in Croatia, you can only be registered to
vote in Croatia. Um, so they're starting to
fix their process.
More recently, um, I need to be careful about
how I describe this, somebody posted a database,
and this one was not posted in in Croatia,
it was posted in the United States, but in
Croatian of all the veterans in Croatia receiving
veterans' benefits. [audience member chuckles]
OK? Um and there were something like 500,000
names on the list. And to be a veteran means
you get like subsided health care, you can
get, uh, you can buy imports without paying
high tariffs, ah you get cheap loans to buy
a house. And there were more than 500,000
names on the list. The problem is, is that
when the war, when the Balkan war ended, there
were only 300,000 veterans. The ruling party
had been adding names to the list of whoever
they wanted to do a favor for and so they
discovered when this list was posted that
there were politicians who had maybe, quote,
"served a week" ah who were being listed as
veterans and getting these benefits. Um, when
this happened Marko was arrested. He was briefly
held, uh, by the police. They searched all
his computers. Uh, they couldn't find anything,
luckily for him. Um and if you say to Marco,
well ah nobody, you know, if you ask him who
leaked the databases, you know, nobody knows.
If you say to him, well, nobody really knows
how the data was leaked, he'll say, "Well,
actually it was on CDs" um, with a wink. OK?
I think of Marko as a data transparency revolutionary.
Um, and I think there are lots of people like
him around the world. But I think it's important
to ask a question about him. So the second
database, the one with the veterans benefits,
that was posted on servers in the United States,
it actually, like, was hit millions of times
in the first few weeks uh that it came out,
the demand from inside Croatia was so big.
But what if, I don't know, let's say Croatia
was like a really close ally of the United
States and some senator, you know, called
on the company that was hosting the servers
to take it down because it was stolen material,
right, and then that company took it down,
kicked them off their servers, what would
we think?
Um, the second story I want to tell you is
about um the problem of, I guess, I guess,
I would call this the problem of illegitimate
secrecy of when governments try to hide information
that citizens know should also be let loose
into the world to, uh, expose and deal with
corruption. Um it's the case of the British
Parliament, uh, expense records, people familiar
with this story? Um, I mean for years uh,
a couple of journalists have been like foyering
the British Parliament to release the expense
records and they've been just you know deny,
deny, deny, drag their feet, um, after about
five years the Parliament, and exposure in
other ways, the Parliament finally set up
a committee, ah, to start to release the records.
Um, what they were really doing is they set
up a internal secret redaction unit to clean
up the records before they were released so
nothing embarrassing would come out. So, ah,
in May of 2009 the Telegraph, the British
newspaper the Telegraph, actually started
publishing the unexpurgated records and they
were leaked to them by a a guy named John
Wick who is a former SAS officer who is actually
the intermediary for an anonymous source.
We don't know who that person was, we believe
it's somebody who was actually on the staff
of this redaction unit. Um, and Heather Brooke,
who was the journalist who was doing all these
foyer requests writes about this, she says,
"Some of the people on the staff of that unit
were so disgusted by what they saw and by
the lies being told about the delays in releasing
the information that they made a copy of the
data, a mole inside the redaction room made
a copy, later passed it to John Wick." Wick
says that he also was told that critical information
was being removed from the files that would
prevent many of the expense scandals from
being revealed and he said to the, to the
Telegraph at the time, "The ultimate source
was adamant that the key thing was that both
the information and the way in which it was
handled should be in the public domain and
that its release was in the public interest."
Wick also told the press he was personally
dismayed at how much information the government
was collecting on the public and how poorly
it was keeping that information private, saying,
"We've reached the stage in society where
they want to know everything about us, I think
we're entitled to know about them." Now as
a result of this leak, again, it set off a
huge bi-partisan or tri-partisan, uh, political
scandal in England. Uh, various people lost
their jobs including the Speaker of the Parliament,
who's more of a functionary than he is a political
figure but he was covering everybody else's
asses. Um, it also put, lit a fire under the
open data movement in British government and
it's why a guy like Tim Berners-Lee has actually
been able to get in and work with both first
the Labor Government and now more recently
the Conservative Government on all the open
data stuff that the Brits have been doing
which is actually uh at least as good if not
better than what the Obama administration
has been doing. So here's a case where a leak
by a conscientious insider, uh, has really,
um, had dramatically positive effects even
though it was extremely disruptive and embarrassing,
um, to people in power.
So I, I wanted to open with both of those
stories because I think they, uh, point to
the larger promise of the transparency movement.
Um, which I think is both a top down and a
bottom up ah kind of thing. Um, the top down
is from enlightened insiders who recognize
the power of open data and open information
to make institutions work better and to enable
us, the citizens, to do things together and
with government to make, ah, the whole civic
sector work better. Um, and it's also gonna
happen from the bottom up with people doing
it to the powers that be.
Um, how many people here know why Bradley
Manning said he, uh, leaked the stuff that
he leaked, assuming he did indeed do it to
give it to WikiLeaks, which is alleged at
this point, right? Anybody here know what
he, what the reasons are? So all we have right
now are the chat logs that Adrian Lamo, uh,
leaked to Wired magazine and which uh have
been posted, but in those, um and we also
have the back and forth between uh Bradley
Manning and his lawyer, uh, and he has one
friend who's been allowed to visit him in
prison. So there's been little bits of data
that have come out from that and so far there's
been nothing to contradict, uh, what's in
those chat logs. And in the chat logs what
he says is he was serving in Iraq on a military
base, um, and he was given the assignment,
he was in a low-level intelligence job, and
he was given the assignment of looking into
the case of 15 Iraqi insurgents who'd been
arrested by the Iraqi National Police. Um,
and what he discovered, he says, is that they
had been distributing a leaflet critical of
the Prime Minister Maliki. And the leaflet
essentially, after he got it translated, was
titled something like Where Did The Money
Go? It was an anti-corruption pamphlet and
it was dealing with publicly available information
raising questions about corruption inside
the government. And, uh, he got upset because
he thought that we were in Iraq to actually,
uh, help them develop a real democracy including
one that would ferret out corruption and wouldn't
arrest people for spreading that information
and, um, so he went to his superior and his
superior told him to shut up, do his job and,
if anything, find ways to help the Iraqi police
arrest more people like this. That's when
he says he had an epiphany or crisis of conscience.
I mean his words, I'm not using his exact
words, I did quote some of them in the book,
but he says at that point he started seeing
things differently. Um, now I'm not gonna
say whether or not it was the right thing
for him to leak everything, or you know, take
a huge data dump, we could debate that, I
suppose. But I do really want people to understand,
at heart, what Bradley Manning is, is a transparency
activist. OK? Um, and right now he has been
in a U.S. prison, military prison in Virginia
going on nine months, more or less solitary
confinement. The latest thing they've come
up with is to make him strip naked every night
and show up each morning in front of his cell
naked because he apparently joked about the
possibility that he could use the elastic
band in his underwear to cause himself harm.
Um, that's happening right now in our country.
And I think he deserves his day in court.
He may well have to spend a long time in jail
for violating the military code, but you know,
don't we have a system here, rule of law,
people are supposed to get charged at some
point and have a chance to defend themselves?
It's been nine months. So.
Uh, that's it, that's my opening remarks,
um, I'm happy to take questions uh or just
dive into the questions that are here. How
do you want to do this? Come to the mic. I
really believe that the people in the room
should get precedence over the folks here
unless you're one of the people who asked
one of these questions. Uh, but since there
don't seem to be that many votes on the questions
anyway unless you have to refresh the page.
You want to put them up on the screen behind
so people can see? Go ahead.
>>Male audience member#1: Isn't openness and
power, isn't openness always a threat to those
in power? I mean even like policemen they're
arresting people in wiretap for, for, um,
recording the fact that they've stopped them
and they've, they've said outrageous things
to them. Um, you know, what can we do to make
it so that that you know low-level flunkies
even can use closedness to keep themselves
from getting in trouble, for being, for breaking
the law?
>>Micah Sifry: Well, I look I mean I think
what's interesting about the time that we
live in is that the ability to share, uh,
information that matters is now in everybody's
hands. Um, you know, we're only a few years
into this phenomenon of everyone carrying
a networked printing press in their pocket.
Um, so the the old way of doing things, which
is still dominant, which is about control
of information and secrecy and lack of accountability,
is being fundamentally threatened. Um, I mean
what Google does is fundamentally threatening
to the ability of people to, uh, you know,
to lie in your face. Right? Because if if
I'm talking to my member of congress at a,
in a public hearing and they, public event
or something, and they say something and I'm
like that's exactly the opposite of what you
said two years ago. I can actually look it
up, pull it up, play it back to them. Um,
what what happens after that? Right? That's
the moment that we're in now, um, and my argument
is is that we're we're in this like a paradigm
shift. It's gonna be messy and upsetting to
the people in power. And they're gonna say
things like, "You can't have that information.
You stole it." Right? Um, but we now have
it. Uh, not every, in not every case because
somebody leaked it either. Right? It's just
because it's been well organized and put at
our fingertips. Um, and I think that's gonna
be really really disruptive to the current
generation and profoundly positive for the
next generation. 'Cause I also think we're
gonna get new leaders, we're gonna get new
folks in all kinds of positions of authority
who are gonna go, "Well, I actually can do
a better job if I'm open." My, my constituency,
my audience, my patients, you know, whoever
the people are that I work with, um, my community
that I'm supposed to protect and serve can
actually make me smarter and better at what
I do. Right? They can be eyes and ears too.
So the issue is, ah, we have to spread that
idea, we have to, we have to advocate for
it, we have to explain to people not to be
scared, I mean a lot of the reason why I wrote
this book is not to educate folks in this
room, I think you guys live and breathe this,
in many ways you take it for granted. Um,
but it's for you to be able to say to your,
you know, family, what, what is all this stuff
and why is it so good or bad? You know a lot
of people are scared by this big change that
we're living through. They just don't get
it. They don't see how the pieces connect
up. And so they're saying things like with
WikiLeaks coming out they're like, "well,
it would be terrible if my all my e-mails
were published or if every business transaction
that I ever do was splashed across the web."
And I think it's important to say to people,
well the issue about user-generated transparency
making its way into the public arena is that
a lot of it is not going to be about your
laundry list or your shopping list, it's gonna
be about some powerful figure or some powerful
institution. The more powerful, the more the
transparency matters. The less powerful, I'd
argue, we need to worry about people with
little power, how do we help protect legitimately,
their privacy? Right? That's a tricky balance.
Um, and sometimes when somebody goes from
having very little power to having a lot,
all of a sudden, like Julian Assange I think
ought to be acting in a much more transparent
way than he is and a lot of the reasons why
I think he's lost credibility is because of
the way he behaves. He is to even the people
in his own core group much too controlling,
much too authoritarian, much too arbitrary
about his decisions. And that's why WikiLeaks
itself, as an organization, is some somewhat
falling apart.
Other questions? Yeah.
>>Male audience member #2: What do you think
about Bill Keller's um actions and the New
York Times' actions with regards to WikiLeaks,
uh, recently and how with the exposé and
basically them dropping a lot of the WikiLeaks
content?
>>Micah Sifry: Yeah. Oh, well, I'm, uh you
know, I'm glad the New York Times decided
to participate and and you know is publishing
some stories. I think it’s a really good
question because of the role the New York
Times plays in the American media system.
Um, to sort of focus a little more closely
on what they are and not what they are doing
and what they're not doing. Um, people may
not realize it, but the New York Times has
the entire State Department archive, uh so
does the Guardian. Um, it's not just WikiLeaks
anymore. I don't know, there may be others.
I think there's a paper in Norway that claims
to have the whole thing. So when the New York
Times doesn't do a story, like right now for
example, Reuters had a story recently going
into detail on corruption in Saudi Arabia.
There's a cable from 1996 which hasn't been
released that they refer to that specifically
describes how the Saudi royal family, uh,
sort of spreads the patronage around. Now
you might say, if you're the editor of the
New York Times, Bill Keller, that there's
no news in that cable because we already know
that there's a lot of, you know, patronaging
and corruption. But the fact that the State
Department you know that an ambassador put
it in writing and there's detail and there
are names, to me that's news. Why are they
holding back on that cable? Um, and the only
plausible answer you can give is that the
New York Times is too close to the U.S. government.
Um, and that we have put a little bit too
much power in the hands of the Times' editor's
judgment. They have admitted, I mean, I've
talked to David Sanger, who's, ah, their chief
Washington correspondent, I've been on panels
with him, that they did not know the importance
of the cables on Tunisia. They have admitted
that when they got their hands on the full
cable set, that no one could possibly read
250,000 cables, so what did they do? They
searched on keywords. Um, you know, they did
enterprise journalism the way you would, which
is, you know, they let different reporters
who know different beats sort of look for
patterns. But they've never read them all.
Um, no one has. Which astounds me, because
it its that could be the Rosetta stone in
some ways or a partial Rosetta stone to unraveling
how the world has been run for the last 10
or 15 years and um, you know, I think we would
agree that a lot of that information, yeah,
sure, redact out the names of individuals
who might be harmed because there are human
rights activists or they're informants and
you need to protect them. But all the other
stuff, why are they holding it back? Now,
they say, they send every time they do a story
they check with the State Department. Which
is effectively saying we check with the government,
um, and then we'll hold some things back.
Uh, um, I mean I think, you know, there ought
to be a demand put to the Times or you know
that we, I mean I've talked to a few people.
It's a matter of figuring out whether there's
a way to press this, uh, more forcefully,
um, to open up that archive. Uh, you know
or open it up responsibly, like turn it in
to something that you know people can check
in and do research and check out or you know
I'm not saying dump the whole thing on the
web indiscriminately. So I, I think there
are real questions about the Times. Um, on
the other hand, I thought Bill Keller was
eloquent in defending the principle of the
freedom of the press to publish this and he
has sort of reluctantly said that yeah, you
know, he would even defend Julian Assange's
right to publish. I mean it's kind of gross
the way, uh, Keller kind of wants to treat
Assange as this, you know, he's, I mean, I,
you know, he really has gone out of his way,
you know, he smells, he doesn't wash. I mean
to point those things out is is a real form
of "he's not one of us, we're we're responsible
and he's not". And you know there are plenty
of investigative journalists who are not pleasant
people. I don't know if you know any. They,
they tend to be really driven, uh, somewhat
secretive, pain in the asses. I've edited
a few of them over the years. And, but they're
the ones who you know often do the digging
to expose the stuff that needs to be exposed.
Um, and I just thought Keller, at one point,
he did this event at Columbia and he said,
uh, something about how Assange changed his
mind about redacting information after Amnesty
International complained. And and Keller said
I'm sure Assange, you know his constituency
probably leans more toward the Amnesty International
crowd. And that was a defense. I mean, it
was like, why does Bill Keller think he has
to insult Amnesty International? They do incredibly
vital work on behalf of political, you know,
I mean who else does this? You know? And they
just write letters to, you know, governments,
to get them to treat their political prisoners
slightly better. So. Very troubling. The New
York Times it’s a very powerful and not
very transparent institution that, uh, I think
we have to pay close attention to and try
and get them to open up.
On this side.
>>Male audience member #3: So your opening
stories were very fascinating and the one
involved the Croatian blogger
>>Micah Sifry: Hmm
>>Male audience member #3: you asked at the
end a question whether what would we think
if the U.S. government shut down his website
that is currently hosted in the U.S.
>>Micah Sifry: Right
>>Male audience member #3: and I don't know
the answer, but I will think about it. So
instead of giving the answer that I don't
know, I ask you a similar question.
>>Micah Sifry: OK
>>Male audience member #3: And a similar story.
The, uh, my native country is Hungary, so
I, I still follow politics there and uh, there,
there was, there is, an infamous website,
extremely anti-Semitic website and it was
so extreme that even the Hungarian government
found it too extreme and it was sued and eventually
they shut it down. So among other things it
listed every journalist who was Jewish, his
home home address and phone number.
>>Micah Sifry: Umhum
>>Male audience member #3They were very careful
not say 'hey, go and kill them' right because
this would be hate speech. Only a list. Objective
list. Information. So what they did after
they shut down, they moved the web server
to New Jersey and the and this is the end
of the story. So right now they operate it
from New Jersey and so what do you think we
should do?
>>Micah Sifry: It's a good question. So in
general it's a great hard question. Um. So
my, my personal feeling is uh that we don't
want to create a system of of you know shutting
down speech. Uh, as long as it's speech. OK?
Um, and so the question is, if it's direct
incitement of violence or not. Um, and I would
err very much on, in the direction of leave
it up as long as it is not direct incitement
of violence and take other measures to protect
people if they need to be protected. The the
thing about posting people's personal information,
it's offensive to do it. Um, but if you create
a system that says it can't, you know, in
other words that polices and can shut places
down simply for posting somebody's personal
information, what I worry is how that's gonna
get used when it's not something as offensive
as the kind of speech you're talking about,
but it's just critical of somebody in power.
OK? Um, and you know, like, there was a recent,
uh, this came up about a year or two ago,
uh, uh, Michael Arrington at Face, at TechCrunch
went after Facebook for leaving up groups
that, uh, deny the holocaust. Right? Um, and
Facebook, you know it's a messy situation
because they also don't have the manpower
to like monitor every new group as soon as
it's put up so you know these groups get on
to the site and people join them and um and
you know so some people were just hammering
at Facebook for allowing holocaust deniers
to create groups on the site. And you know
Facebook's policy is as long as these groups
are not directly advocating violence against
others, we're gonna let them exist. It's speech.
Um, and you know we have a tradition of allowing
robust free speech in the United States, uh
and that we generally believe the way to combat
bad speech isn't by suppressing it, but by
with better speech, with more speech. Um,
personally I think it's kind of a good thing
if you, you know, if this happens on Facebook
'cause even there, if they're enforcing their
rules about you know people having to use
their real name and picture, you can kind
of go on these groups and go 'that person's
a holocaust denier'. You know, I mean he's
made himself public in a way. Um, we're not
gonna get rid of holocaust denial by hiding
it. We're not gonna get rid of anti-Semitism
by suppressing it. We have to, you know, we
have to deal with it. The way you deal with
it is by exposing it and arguing with it and
marginalizing it. That that's my view. The
place where it crosses over is are people
using these sites to organize acts of violence
against other people? That's where law, you
know, other laws come into play. I don't know
if that's a perfect answer. I mean, you're
asking like absolutely one of the hardest
edge questions. And it's the one where those
of us who are civil libertarians about speech
run into trouble. You know the ACLU defended
the right of the Nazis to march in a Jewish
neighborhood in Skokie, Illinois. And they
lost like a quarter of their members, who
were Jewish probably, who were so offended
by that. But you know the point of free speech
is we have to protect unpopular speech. I
mean my argument about defending WikiLeaks
in part is that, it's not that I endorse every
single thing that they do, I just don't like
the idea that a, a, all it takes is a threatening
phone call from Joe Lieberman's senate office
to somebody at Amazon for Amazon to completely
cave in and and kick WikiLeaks off their servers.
There's no criminal case. And it's not like
WikiLeaks is posting copywrited material,
which was another one of the reasons which
Amazon gave for kicking WikiLeaks off their
servers. You can't copywrite government documents.
They're born uncopywrited. OK? So you know
Amazon's reasons were just completely bogus.
And, you know, they used to say that you should
put your stuff in the cloud because that's
a, you know, it will be more secure there.
Well now you have to worry whether the company
that's hosting your stuff in their cloud is
gonna, you know, uh, crumble under the tiniest
bit of government pressure. I mean I have
to say that I was very happy that when the
question was posed to Eric Schmidt, what did
you guys think about you know indexing links
to WikiLeaks' disclosures? He says, yeah we
had a conversation about it and we decided
to keep doing it 'cause it's legal. Like that's
the right answer. Later, you can, you know,
well, if there's a criminal case and fine,
we'll abide by the law. But noth-, none, none
of that's happened.
Other questions? Yeah.
>>Male audience member #4 Uh, do you think
the uh the way they're treating Private Manning
is more to get him to implicate Assange as
a co-conspirator or is it more to have a chilling
effect on any potential like future whistle
blowers? And do you think it will achieve
either one of those?
>>Micah Sifry: It's definitely to intimidate
other potential whistle blowers. I think they
really want to send a message to other people
in the Army um that you know this is worse
than you know torturing people in Abu Ghraib.
You know, we're gonna, we're gonna treat you
worse. I mean I think it's despicable, but
that's their, you know, they this is about
enforcing their chain of command. Um, and,
you know, the fact that General Petraeus could
leak his highly-classified proposal for expanding
the war in Afghanistan to Bob Woodward, which
then made front-page news on the Washington
Post and was used to undermine Obama's own
planning process. Right? Like nobody's, ah,
prosecuting him or or putting him in solitary.
Um, so they're definitely trying to send a
message. I mean there's a theory that they're
also trying to break him and, and, um, somehow
get him to implicate, ah, WikiLeaks, um, I,
I don't know, I don't know whether they're
that willful or its more just this is the
military discipline system. I mean, you know,
I recently wrote a blog post where I said
you know I mean if this is meant to be mental
torture, what's so troubling about it is,
what it could do is that at the point of when
he does finally get his day in court he won't
be sane. Um, he won't be able to help present
his own case. Uh, and that would be a tragedy.
Um, I mean let him make his case. He may not
win, you know, a military jury or judge may
not buy a Nuremberg defense if that's what
he's gonna argue. You know he can argue that.
He can say, soldiers are required to report
uh war crimes under the Nuremberg precedents
which are supposed to govern. And that's all
I, you know, he could say that's what I thought
I was doing. But they're accusing him of aiding
the enemy. That's a pretty serious charge.
So. Yeah.
>>Male audience member #5: If you'll pardon
me for a bit of a tangent. Um, you decided
to, uh, write a relatively short book quickly.
>>Micah Sifry: Yeah.
>> Male audience member #5: Um. I, could you
comment on sort of how viable this is as a
publishing strategy and uh whether you think
it's really, um, economically worthwhile to
put it on paper?
>>Micah Sifry: Great, great, great questions.
You can also ask my editor and publisher John
Oakes over there uh after we're done 'cause
I'm sure he believes it's economically viable.
Um, so the answer is, uh, I'm intrigued by
this possibility of you know the sort of shorter,
quicker, you know, the timeliness of a book.
It's very frustrating as an author to write
a book and then have to wait nine months,
you know, for it to come out and by then you're
already out of date. Um, so when John came
to me in the middle of December and started
to, sort of, woo me into doing this, um, one
of the reasons why I thought, yeah, maybe
I could do it is because he said it just had
to be like 25,000 words and on a good day
I can write three or four thousand words if
I'm in in the right groove. So I thought,
you know, I can do this in a week. It ended
up taking three weeks and it was like 45,000
words. But, um, and then getting it out fast
is the second thing that's very gratifying.
Um, does it make sense to still be on paper?
Well, I'm in the middle of trying to learn,
you know, the plusses and minuses of e-books
myself. I mean, I do both now. Right? Um,
and I love the immediacy of getting that e-book.
[chuckles] Right? Um, and it works for me
with fiction, 'cause I really read linearly
in fiction. But I'm noticing like I, I also
have downloaded all the other WikiLeaks books
and I'm finding it really annoying that I
can't, you know, sort of go to an index or,
you know, jump to somewhere in the middle.
I mean when I pick up a physical book, I,
I, you know, I go like this. I, I, you know,
there's a certain element of just, you know,
find where you're mentioned, [chuckles] you
know, whatever. Which I guess you could do
with search on on an e-book. But it it there's
something about the utility of the paper,
uh, that I like, um, that so far at least
on the Kindle platform, which is what I'm
using, doesn't quite do it. Um, on the other
hand, what I'm really intrigued by we're gonna
actually do, hopefully, right, we're gonna
turn the book into an app and we're gonna
add a couple of features to it, um, basically
three. Uh, one is there are about 15 places
in the book where somebody, uh, who I'm quoting
actually has spoken at one of our Personal
Democracy Forum conferences. Um, so we have
video. Um, and you know we actually have done
a series of WikiLeaks-related events over
the last few months, so we actually have shored
video of people like Jeff Jarvis and so on,
you know, saying really smart things, that
if you're like really into the subject, having
that video right there might make it a richer
reading experience for you or a teaching experience.
Um, so I'm really intrigued by adding that.
We're gonna add, because there are about 40
or 50 websites mentioned in the book, we're
gonna add, sort of, links to screenshots and
then I think if it's being done this way,
you know, click and it'll take you off, out
of the book to that site. And that too, I
think for, for some people, could be a nice
plus. And then the last thing which I'm really,
uh, which I don't think will work for my book,
but I'm willing to try it anyway just to be
a guinea pig, is there are one or two places
where I, I want to insert a discussion point
and actually ask the reader a question. So
this is where I had my epiphany. Alright?
This is, I tell the story in the book about
eight years, seven, eight years ago being
at one of Tim O'Reilly's conferences and seeing
people all using laptops networked with each
other and and in a back channel chat. Right?
Like before it was, before Twitter, before
all the, you know, and that like blew my mind
and I had this experience then of, oh, this
is gonna change like the structure of how
we do stuff in and I'm really curious when
everybody else has had that, you know, I think
a lot of people have had, at one point or
another, that sort of wake-up moment so I
thought let's put a spot in the book where
anybody who's reading it can, you know, stop
and add their comment and then the next time
you upload the book, the comment goes up to
the server and then, you know, you'll see
what other people's comments are. You know,
let's make the book a discussion platform.
Um, the reason why I'm not sure it's gonna
work is my guess is is that you know two percent
of my readers will do that, so I need like
tens of thousands of readers to get a decent
number of comments. Um, but, I really, I mean
I'm intrigued by the e-book because I think
it, it is a, a, it can be exploded into something
that's much more of a, a shared experience.
Um, like Amazon now you can read your, as
you're reading, you'll see sections that have
been underlined by other people. It's, I want
to know what my friends have underlined. Like
I'll read the same book that you're reading
and read your notes. That'll make the book
more interesting to me. Um, so yeah, I'm,
I'm fascinated by it. I'm glad you know this
sort of gives me a chance to maybe sort of
play in that space. So.
Um, we're almost out of time. I suppose we
should take one more, or, yeah.
>>Male audience member #6: Are you sure it's
really a new paradigm? I mean if you know
a leak from WikiLeaks is like the fuel for
the fire, isn't a free press and a society
that wants accountability from its government
sort of the oxygen that that fire burns in?
And so isn't this WikiLeaks stuff just the
latest thing but it’s the same as, you know,
when Woodward and Bernstein got the list of
all the people who worked for Creep and had
to figure out who worked for who by figuring
out which phone numbers were closer together
or that, you know, guy that got arrested and
you know in New Amsterdam, there's somebody,
Peter something or other got arrested.
>>Micah Sifry: John Peter Zenger, yeah.
>>Male audience member #6: Yeah, so.
>>Micah Sifry: Um, here's what's new. You're
right, because it's building on, you know,
we're standing on the shoulders of 500 years
of a free press or an emerging free press.
But only in the last 10 years is it a networked
free press. I mean it used to be said, right,
that the freedom of the press belongs to him
who can own one. Um, I own one. Um, as long
as you don't take the internet down on me,
OK? Uh, that's different. Um, the ability
for small and large groups to swarm around
information and keep it in the open is different.
So I mean, I mean at some point it goes from
being a change in kind and not just a change
in degree. I, you know, we could argue it
doesn't really matter what, you know, where
you come down on that argument. I mean I think
it's an acceleration that we're going through.
Um, it may be not discontinuous. OK? Um, but
I, the way, you know, you guys you work in
an environment where you're like completely
you live and eat and breathe this. OK? Um,
you know, one of the nice things I always
say to myself I'm glad I, I, you know there's
one piece of my life which is just purely
suburban and, you know, I'm with people who
are "normal." Um, so I get to see how a lot
of this is diffusing into people's lives much
more slowly and in very confusing and scary
ways. And I do think people need help understanding
why this is healthy and not something to just
have a knee-jerk fear response to. Um, and
also for younger people, how they can get
involved. Um, especially younger people, though
it would be great if we could get folks with
free time, called senior citizens, more involved
in this too, but. Um, so that's, you know
so some of it may be is just a marketing ploy
to, you know, [chuckles] how do you sell ideas?
You make big claims about them. Uh, it makes
it easier for people to spread them. So I
do, you know, the age of transparency is one
way of making an argument about what's different
about now compared to, um, ten years ago.
And I, I do think it's different. I mean,
it used to be that there was lots of information
that was technically public, but completely
hidden in plain sight . Right? Like, unless
you had the time and money to drive down to
Washington D.C., make an appointment at the
FEC or at, uh, you know uh, uh, the House
of Representatives, where you could go into
the room to open the paper records that show
who is donating to who, or how much a particular
member of congress was paying his staffer.
I mean that's public record, but difficult
to access. Now you can access it in a matter
of seconds. Uh, and when they hold it back,
see this is what I mean by paradigm shift.
Um, the argument for holding it back is is
often, was well, we can't afford to make it
available in every library in the country,
so we're just gonna put it in a few. Uh, or
you know, you'll have to come make an appointment
to look up this information. Like the Justice
Department for example, requires every lobbyist
from a foreign country to register and provide
very detailed information on the lobbying
that they're doing. And it's only because
of the Sunlight Foundation, which I, I'm an
advisor to, starting to digitize those records
so that now you, because they're all written
in hand. People don't realize these are paper
records filled out in hand. You have to code
them in. Uh, that they're starting to move
to a system that will make those records digital
by default. But the argument in this day and
age is if something should be, is required
to be public, it should be online they those
things should become synonymous. So at Sunlight
we've actually been pushing something called
the POIA bill. Public Online Information Act.
Um, to require that going forward any document
that's generated that is required to be public
is not sufficiently public until it is also
online in searchable and downloadable and
machine readable format if if that's relevant.
So we have a lot of work to do. So I'm gonna
end by saying, you guys, help us out. If you're
not already, ah, you know supporting Sunlight
for example, get involved. Go to sunlightfoundation.com.
They have a developer community of more than
2,000 people who pitch in, uh, on projects.
Um, the other way to get involved is to help
explain it. Uh, you know, that's why I wrote
this book. Uh, give people a tool that sort
of put connects the dots and uh makes an argument
for why this is actually really healthy for
our democracy. And let's not let the people
who sort of knee jerk wanna go back to controlling
information and saying, "Trust us, we know
what's right", you know, to hold sway. Because
at the moment we are we are in a turning-point
moment. The WikiLeaks thing is a turning-point
moment for a lot of people in this administration
who said they were for open government and
now are, you know, kind of silent, and people
who want to clamp down on, on information.
And there are other bad ideas relating to
uh, you know, back doors into e-mail and stuff
like that. There's a lot of bad stuff that
these folks still would like to try and do.
So, we have a fight. Anyway, thank you for
coming. We've gone our hour, right?
>>Female presenter: Thank you. [clapping]